Brian: Where are we?
Ben: This is
the last stage of the journey.
We finally made it.
This is it.
Brian: How do we know
this is the place?
Ben: This is where
he writes his code, I'm sure.
It's where the emails
have been coming from.
Brian: are you sure?
Ben: Yeah.
We've been tracking
his IP address right here.
This has gotta be the building
where the genius lives.
Brian: This is private property.
I don't think we should be--
Wait, where are you going?!
Ben:
No one's ever seen him.
Brian: We can't go in there.
Ben: We've gotta find
him--come here.
Oh, my God! Look at this.
Brian: Wow.
Ben: I don't know if
we're supposed to be--
Brian: This is really freaky.
Ben: No, come on.
Down here.
You know, he works alone.
I'm sure of that.
Brian: Wait, so who reviews
his code?
Ben: Nobody reviews his code.
What do you think, we're worthy?
He's a genius.
I mean,
he's all over the internet.
Brian: But he works
with a whole team.
I mean, what if he gets stuck
down a rat hole?
Ben:
You think he wants feedback?
I mean, that's ridiculous.
Who's gonna give him feedback?
You know what happened
to the last guy
who gave him feedback?
Do you remember what happened?
Wait, wait.
This could be it.
No, wait.
I hear something in here.
I hear something.
We're gonna go in.
Are you ready?
You gonna come with me?
Ben: We need to go.
Brian: You gonna go first?
All right, I'm going in.
Ready?
Let's go.
Oh, my God!
Genius: Who are you?
Brian: Are you the genius?
What are you working on?
>> He's writing code,
I'll bet.
Genius: Hey, no, stop.
Don't look at that!
Get out of here!